we just got his PhD from MIT and he's
got a fellow here sitting up there was
about using the summer squash hierarchy
for these types of problems oh cool yeah
so this talk is gonna be about two very
related problems what Daniel just talked
about in high dimensional robust
estimation this is joint work with Sam
Hopkins who's right now postdoc at
Berkeley so here's the outline so yeah
as I mentioned it's going to be about
two very related topics and high
dimensional estimation and robust
estimation the first is about learning
whilst I pretty mixtures of gaussians
which Daniel already talked about and
the second one is about robust
estimation of we mean which I guess
Daniel also sort of talks about but I
guess we're going to be considering this
from a different perspective and getting
slightly different results I'm gonna
tell you how to solve these problems if
we could somehow find bounded subsets of
data in some in some very explicit sense
and then I'm gonna tell you how to find
these bounded subsets which is going to
be some very you know very high moment
condition on these subsets using the sum
of squares method and as a result we get
an efficient method with improper arted
so Danny already talked about this some
extent but mixture models are the
following you have samples from a
mixture of K distributions D 1 through D
K so it happens is I have do you want to
DK and then to generate a sample from
them I just simply first choose one of D
1 to D K uniformly at random and then I
get a sample from that distribution this
is a uniform mixture you can also get
your non-uniform mixtures where you draw
samples with non uniform mixing weights
but for now let's consider a uniform
case for simplicity and each one of
these distributions has some mean mu 1
to MU K and your goal is to learn the
means of these distributions or more
generally learn these distributions but
in this talk we're gonna focus mostly on
learning the means and clustering the
data ok so the picture it's kind of like
this we have like the red data and the
green data and they're from different
subsets and you don't get these colors
and our goal is to recover the colors
this is very popular very widely use
generative practical and practice and
arguably the most interesting setting
for practice and in theory the most
difficult at least is setting where
there's many clusters and also the
dimensionality data is very high okay so
in this talk D is going to be the
dimension that K is going to be number
of mixtures and we're going to think of
D and K as both growing in for
simplicity let's just say K and D are
more or less the same thing although we
can you know you can generalize this and
the goal is for all these things to get
polynomial in D and K both in sample
complexity and time complexities is what
we're going to try to get in this talk
okay so arguably the most well studied
and most classical and also probably the
most popular mixture model are those of
gaseous mixture models which are
introduced back in 1894 by Pearson and
this simply where the components di are
gaussians with mean mu and covariance
Sigma I so the idea is sort of is that
maybe you have some sort of
heterogeneous population say consisting
of multiple different subpopulations
that within each sub population you know
perhaps things are relatively you know
bell curve ish but because we're
combining them without labels it's not
you don't get our overall bell curve you
get some sort of make sure it we just
kind of picture that we're getting here
okay so what was known so it turns out
that this problem is just hard so
information theoretically even a one
dimension a mixture of keg options
requires two to the Omega K samples to
learn the parameters information
theoretically so even in one dimension
if we want to get poly DK samples were
already running into issues and so where
the picture is what's happening is you
can kind of hide the parameters of the
guy so you can hide of you can have one
cache which looks at this and you can
vary like precisely match it but to make
sure many other regressions okay so
somehow this vanilla setting is just
hard information theoretically because
you can hide this data so somehow to get
past this exponential barrier you need
some additional assumptions or you need
to somehow weaken the problem okay so
how do you do this so one way is as I
think I'm shy I said as you can do
density estimation instead of learning
the parameters you can try to you know
just get something which is close in
total variation distance okay so there's
then studied a lot and one to mention
these are yeah so here's the goal is
just output hypothesis which is close on
TV distance and this is good because it
only requires poly DK number of samples
but there are no efficient algorithms as
far as we can tell for this problem
particular the best known runtimes for
this problem are still exponential in D
and also sometimes in K okay so that
kind of sucks so this is a nice
information theoretic criteria but we
just don't know algorithms for it at
least for now there's other assumptions
for instance non degeneracy or smooth
analysis is where you somehow assume
that the mean there's something are sort
of have these nice algebraic properties
that they're like somehow in general
position and in this case you can do
stuff like tensor decomposition and this
works but in this talk we're going to
consider another equally well studied
and natural condition which I think
Daniel already mentioned which is
separation which is we're just going to
assume that the Lt distance between the
means is at least Delta for all mu mu J
for all I not equal to J okay so the
picture is supposed to be
yeah so here's our assumption we're
going to assume UI minus PJ's at least
Delta for all I not equal J and to make
this assumption meaningful you need some
notion of scale so in this talk we're
going to assume that the Sigma eyes are
PSD bounded by one because otherwise you
know you need some notion of scale for
this makes sense and now the picture at
least in theory supposed to be like you
know you know being separated by Delta
okay and so these are sort of that's the
picture okay so what's so the whole name
of the game in this setting is to get as
small Delta as possible right the
smaller the separation that you need for
you I'll give them the more general and
more powerful your algorithm is so the
question is what kind of Delta is needed
to learn them you guys so last year we
Gavin Vijaya okay I can't pronounce it
so RV 17 said showed that you can get
separation which is a Omega root LOC a
with polynomial and DNK samples but they
gave a very inefficient a Beulah they
give it to the K time algorithm so this
sort of gives the information theoretic
answer turns out this is actually Titan
more or less so then the National
question is what about efficient
algorithms so this is sort of like
folklore ax methods at a separation
which is roughly rootkit a root D and
this can be improved this was improved
by the scooped in Schulman in 2002 D to
the 1/4 for spherical gems and then it
was later improved by the Apollo Wang
and cut on Kumar to get separation which
is like K to the 1/4 okay but it's
actually at this point roughly in 2004
progress on this problem stop and you
can see there's there's a like a
exponential gap for a K to the one first
versus boot law K for inefficient versus
efficient algorithms ok so you know the
question is you know Kenyon can you
improve this and our contribution is the
show yes so our result is amongst others
other container contemporaneous works
the first efficient algorithm to achieve
separation which is much less than K to
the 1/4 for learning GMM so here is our
theorem
for any epsilon greater than zero if the
separation is K to the epsilon then
there's an algorithm which takes D to
the oh of 1 over epsilon squared samples
in time and recovers the DUI to err 1
over K to the 100 word so there's just
supposed to be a large polynomial in 1
over k we just have covariance need to
be bounded by the identity yes I think
this slightly generalized is what you
were able to do in your paper for the
Gaussian mixture model setting okay and
if you push this kind of as far as you
can go you can actually show that if
Delta is C root K then there's in fact
an algorithm which takes
quasi-polynomial in many samples in
quasi-polynomial time and recovers mu i
to the same sort of accuracy so we can
get sort of this information theoretic
special recall that root log K was sort
of the boundary for what was possible
information theoretically so we can
almost get this in polynomial time but
yeah ok so there's a number of comments
I should make about this so our results
hold not only Ferguson's with Van Dyck
covariance but also for mixtures of
distributions with some sort of
explicitly bounded moments those moments
with some nice structure which I'll
mention a little bit later in this talk
and as I mentioned before our v7 poop
our v17 showed that if the separation is
much less than root log K then you need
quasi-polynomial in your sample so
really we're really hitting that
threshold at least in quasi-polynomial
time and you know right now we're
stating this accuracy is 1 over key to
the hundreds of some large polynomial 1
over K turns out that you know for
spherical gouges at least you can get
arbitrary accuracy by using this to
first like get some pretty good estimate
and then like our V 17 also gave some
like efficient algorithm for really
getting once you have a very good
estimate of the means getting it like
arbitrarily close okay and I should say
the similar results were obtained
independently by Daniel do connect close
Kane Stewart and Kothari Steinhardt so
these are all concurrent works okay so
this is pretty cool I think but now let
me tell you about another problem which
is perhaps on the surface slightly
unrelated so this is you know this is
robust statistics workshop so yes they
should talk about this so here the
problem is we're given samples from the
Gaussian with mean mu covariance
identity and RD but an epsilon fraction
of the points are arbitrarily corrupted
and the goal is to learn me okay so the
picture is like we have these nice blue
samples from a Gaussian but then an
adversary is you know corrupted them
have these red points remove some points
and now the goal is given these points
without the color still recover the mean
not in like our two button Rd okay so
this is a very classical problem this is
first studied back in the 60s and 70s by
Tookie and Huber is a very seminal works
and it's stronger but morally equivalent
I think more or less up to maybe small
factors to this notion of model
specification model miss specification
where the goal is you know we we have
some idealized model but we don't get
samples from this idealized model
instead we get samples from this
idealized model plus some perturbation
for this perturbation is uncontrolled so
we get samples from this and our goal is
to you know recover information about
this even though all we know is that
we're modeling like this but it's not
quite a Gaussian it's sort of this
robustness yeah
okay so what's known about this Trump
well when the dimensionality of the
problem is low it's actually not too
hard it turns out for instance in d
equals 1 you can use the median and this
gets error of Epsilon
but when D is large there's actually
kind of this is not so easy
so to key back in 75 okay something
called a to key median which also gave
arrow of epsilon so this is this is the
right information theoretic answer but
the algorithm is inefficient and recent
algorithms by joint work with dick
Nicholas Cain cometh Moira Stuart and
also ly Ralph and Paula gave algorithms
that more or less get something like
this epsilon root log 1 over Epsilon
in particular you know there's no
dimension dependence in so this was a so
this required some effort and actually
you can actually mash as it turns out
with efficient algorithms same set of
authors as the 16 paper that I was on
gets over Epsilon so this is like you
know very very nice I think oh ok I
guess I shouldn't say that this is I
think right this is interesting but
there's also some you know specification
going on here and we don't want our like
we don't want our robust algorithms to
be over specified to the you know the
model because that kind of ruins the
point of robustness
in particular it turns out that some of
these like settings are really heavily
using the algebraic structure of
gaussians right and somehow that can be
detrimental if you want to use these
things in practice because maybe this
maybe the data is in really truly
Gaussian okay maybe just has a nice
concentration and so sort of intuitively
all you need about these distributions
to be able to learn the mean efficiently
or information theoretically is to have
good concentrations a good subconscient
concentration some couching
concentration so a natural question to
ask is you know now if I'm given samples
from a distribution D where D is just a
sub Gaussian distribution with mean mu
and variance bounded by the identity but
where an epsilon fraction of the samples
are still arbitrarily corrupted can you
learn me in this
more general setting okay and for people
who I know just to be clear so a sub
cash and distribution just means that
the gap the distribution concentrates
better than a Gaussian in every
direction
so in one dimension you know a
distribution D sub Gaussian if the
moments are controlled by that big ocean
because that implies that it
concentrates better than that of a
Gaussian and in D dimensions and says
that if I project along any unit vector
I also get this sort of nice suggestion
moment structure okay
so in this setting what is known well
information theoretically you can still
get o of Epsilon just because really all
we need about these distributions to be
able to recover the mean is just that
they have nice concentration but
efficient algorithms turns out they're
still sort of a gap so if the covariance
is known to be the identity then you
still can get these nice
perhaps not reblog when were epsilon
rates but for general sigma when Sigma
is unknown the best known error as far
as we could tell was root epsilon so now
there's still some sort of gap you you
know it should be epsilon there's a root
epsilon so not quite an exponential gap
but there's still some gap here the
question was you know can we bridge
these two settings it turns out you can
so we give an algorithm that is able to
get error which is much less than root
epsilon efficiently so here's a theorem
for any T in the National numbers if D
has sub - in teeth moment so if that
inequality I shows you holds up to all
Chi and this fact has a simple proof
which I'll get into in a bit but it
turns out this is quite a general
condition then there's an algorithm and
the efficient algorithm that gets error
which is epsilon to the 1 minus 1 over T
with this sort of runtime and sample
complexity so in particular for any
fixed T you know if say T is a you know
for this is already epsilon to the 3/4
so they're ready better than then root
epsilon and it's polynomial and you get
arbitrarily you kind of push that to any
arbitrary constant and as before we can
sort of push this if we're willing to
get quasi-polynomial time and match sort
of the original guarantees so if T has
sub - Ian you know log on a replica
moments and again this has a simple
proof whatever that means then there's
an algorithm which gets error epsilon
root log 1 over Epsilon so the same area
that we got before with quality
polynomial yeah many samples n time so
is the running time actually won over a
restaurant or a fixed constant
independency I mean yeah let me think
about this
I guess mmm perhaps not eat it
what one needs to check these thing yeah
yeah there might be I want to wraps onto
the cheat here
although ok then it probably is okay
yeah sorry so that the title
and yeah similar results were obtained
independently by two papers by Kothari
Steinhardt guitar story
so again sound concurrent work but again
yeah so this is a you know these are two
problems which are at the surface
somewhat you know perhaps technically
unrelated you know why why am i
presenting them both at the same time
well it turns out that there is a very
nice technical connection between these
two problems which is that for both of
them it's a physis to find a subset of
my data which has empirically bounded
teeth moments okay what does this mean
so let me define this for you so let x1
through xn be my data center Rd for any
subset of n let me sub s to note the
empirical mean of that subset it's just
some notation and then here's my
definition for any subset of my data set
we say that this subset has some
Gaussian teeth moments if the sort of
sub Gaussian moment inequality I showed
you before of degree T holds for all
directions u so if I project my data and
a direction you after centering by my
empirical mean then this empirical data
set has bounded teeth elements up to
some small slack for concentration
issues
is this definition make sense is it
gonna be kind of important so no this is
this is just no this is a small constant
to get you know concentration of this
you'll need to take two to the T samples
this kind of thing but this is just some
small slack to account for any like
generalization
yeah just generalization exactly yeah
you shouldn't yeah it feels like it
feels truly it shouldn't be here but we
just need some slack to make sure that
it's realizable is this make sense this
is just saying that you know my moments
of my data set of my sunset my data look
like that of a Gaussian in every
direction okay
right and if you just plug in what you
know the form of that is it just really
this T to the 2 over 2 times l2 you know
I'm I can use that's it maybe there's a
constant that I'm forgetting again okay
so that the claim for both these problem
is that if I can find a sub - and subset
of my data that is of the appropriate
size and has the kind of the right T
then I can solve both of these problems
so here's what I mean by that if x1
through xn are samples for my GMM with
seperation Delta and uniform weights so
let me define T sub I to be the set of
points what truly came from component I
so they're the points which are truly
sampled from the earth component and we
know you know roughly speaking because
this is a uniform make sure that roughly
1 over K fraction of the point should
come from any component so T I should
have size roughly n over K and the
theorem is that if we can find a sub -
in subsets of my data of the same size
with you know 100 over epsilon moments
then this must be close to some G I so
if n is sufficiently large and Delta is
at least k to the epsilon and I found a
sub - a subset of the same size which
with this many founded moments then the
intersection of s with some TI must be
at least must be almost all of Ti so 1
minus some big polynomial in 1 over K ok
so this says if I can find a sub - and
subset of my data then I could solve
GM's ok and similarly for robust mean
estimation if x1 through xn are an
epsilon cap that set of samples from a
distribution D which is sub Gaussian and
has mean mu and variance bounded by the
identity if I let teeth denote the
subset of uncorrupted points by the
definition of my problem I know that T
is of size at least 1 minus epsilon
times n because the adversary is only
allowed to add an epsilon fraction of
bad points
then my theorem is that if I can find
another subset s of the same size 1
minus epsilon n that also has sub - in
teeth moments then the empirical mean of
this subset s - a true mean must be very
close must be exactly what we're looking
for
C times T to the 1/2 times out sum to 1
minus 1 over G ok
okay so let me show you actually the
proofs of this actually let me the
proofs of both of them are actually
quite similar but I think the proof for
GM's is slightly cleaner so let me
present that okay so the key lemma that
we're going to need for this is the
following which is that if s and T are
both substance my data with Sebastian
teeth moments then we have this
inequality as intersect T the size of it
times the difference between the means
raised to the T is that mostest to two
though of T times T the T over two times
the size of s but there's some intuition
here the idea is that like what this is
saying is that either there's like no
intersection between us and cheek or if
there's any intersection that means must
be close and in this very quantitative
sense when you raise it to the teeth
power and this is the this is very
important okay so let me show you why
this key lemma would imply our theorem
which you know
recall that the what we wanted to show
is that you know if you could find this
sub gaussian subset of points of size
roughly on over k and this must be close
to some true gaussian component i'm
gonna be slightly sketchy so suppose I
have the key lemma that what I'm gonna
say is that the ti the true component
the true cluster of any component is
going to have a gaussian teeth moments
by just gaussian concentration if I take
enough samples and moreover the
empirical mean of the teeth component or
the sorry Ti so the samples from this
component is very close to the true mean
of that component okay so let me just
assume this true moreover we have the
separation condition that because you
know what we're assuming is that the mu
sub I mu sub T sorry the Meuse of Izar
Delta separated so that means mu sub s
can be at most you know k to the epsilon
over to close to one of the TI just by
triangles
quality you know we have lots of points
with your far apart I can only be close
to one of them whatever my muse the BES
is okay but that means that for
everything else for all J not equal to
this 1ti we have that forty being this
large constant just plug it in with
setting this to be K to the epsilon over
two and so if you just move that over
here the point is that you know this K
to the epsilon is kind of it's going to
be canceled by this a by this one over
epsilon here so we're going to get some
large one hundred here so this point
this guy is going to move over here and
it's going to be really large or small
small all right so if you just like do
that manipulation you get this and I
claim that because you know K to the
epsilon T has been chosen so said this
is really small you're going to get
something which is very small overlap
with any other TJ
that make sense it looks like you prefer
you corrupt absolute fraction of your
data right oh yeah this is our this is
for the Gaussian mixture models I see so
this is not the same as oh sorry yeah
this epsilon is different this epsilon
is like my separation is Kate to the
epsilon yeah so this is why we need you
know that's why we're getting this K to
the minus epsilon T
but okay hopefully that made sense the
point is that you know because we have
this extremely strong condition on the
teeth moment for you know more or less
any tea we can just use this to amplify
the seperation exponentially so all we
need to do is prove this key lemma and
the proof of this will rely on two very
simple facts and this will be very
important later on the first is a
holders inequality or some very basic
form of holders inequality which is the
following which is if a and B are real
numbers and T is a power of two then a
plus B quantity to the T is less than
two to the T times a to the C plus B to
the T it's not actually really holders
inequalities like a very simple form of
it but it's true you can check it the
second is again this is x2 sort of
holders inequality but it's more or less
the same thing which is if I have M
summons a1 through a.m. which are real
numbers and T is again a power 2 then if
I take some of the a I quantity basis of
T I can push the exponent inside the sum
and I pay em to them t minus 1 and so I
get this quantity ok so this is actually
like a consequence of holders but both
of these facts are very simple to check
and they're true ok so now with these
two things let me prove this key lemma
so we're going to start by rewriting
things we're going to start by writing
rewriting some weird quantity this
quantity me
we're not
Oh
oh my god
okay we're gonna write it as this so X
intersect e to the T times Miu s minus
beauty norm to the 2t so we're going to
start by writing some really dumb stuff
we're gonna write s intersect e as the
sum of I and s intersect T of 1 to the T
and we're gonna write the this is the L
2 norms you know to the 2t so this is
this to the T this is all very basic
stuff right now and then we can do
something again stupid we can push this
this thing inside the sum still so far
haven't done anything interesting then
we're going to add a subtract x i4i in s
intersect key all right so this is the
first time anything in the summon xu is
non-trivial cos now things at least
depend on X I and now I'm going to use
our first fact we have a sum of two
things raised to the T so we're going to
split them up and pay to the chief so
we're gonna get this okay so these two
terms are more or less the same the only
difference is that there's a mutti here
versus of us here but the analysis is
going to be symmetric with respect to
both of these things so let me just
consider one of these terms and then the
analysis will be the same
to the other one
okay so this is the first term this is a
sum of you know I and s intersect key of
MU sub s minus X I inner product u sub s
minus mu sub T to the t's is a first
time I rode out and now we're going to
use my second fact I have a sum of you
know this many things sighs the best
intersects cheat many things to the T
I'm gonna push the exponent in I'm gonna
pay this penalty okay so this is this
and now sort of maybe this is kind of
looking like sub - Ian subsets Sebastian
subsets would give you exactly ab
control on this if only you know I had X
into the vested the SEC T because yeah
because then Muse the best would to be
the empirical mean of the points in my
set so I do just be very naive and just
actually pay this I can just say I'm
adding a bunch of non-negative things I
can just add in some more non-negative
things and this is still going to be
true and now I can literally use the
definition of sub - and subsets okay so
get this quantity so this is this
follows directly from the definition of
suggestion subsets tête with this test
vector mu sub s minus nu sub t
and so overall
what we get is this bend which looks a
bit messy but I claim that if you
simplify everything you get exactly the
band that you wanted so it's C so this t
minus 1 cancels all but one of that this
G cancels this and then when you
simplify you just good everything works
out ok so this is a very clean proof in
some sense and this more or less has
this more or less completes the proof
that I want to show that if you have
some guys and subsets you can identify
the means of some cluster ok cool
so now we have this powerful looking
technology but like how do we actually
find these bounded subsets so this is
kind of you know non-trivial so just as
a recap what would be shown is that it
suffice is to find a subset of my data
which has these sub Gaussian moments
that these these empirically sagashi
moments you know but how do you do this
in general this is a very non convex
looking prom this is this problem that I
just showed you like it has it's like
finding subset the data and it also has
like teeth powers which I Daniel
mentioned is like or like you know it's
some sort of like teeth tensor thing so
in general seems a computationally
tractable to do so what we're going to
do is we're going to relax this problem
using something called the somewhat
squares paradigm which was independently
discovered and rediscovered many times
but at a high level I'm not going to get
into the details of the proof system but
it's a restricted proof system which
allows you to verify non negativity of
multi no multivariate polynomials ok so
some some Troup system and the point of
this proof system is that if you can
find this proof then this proof can also
be found algorithmically via some SDP so
there's some restricted proof system I
can't verify non negativity of all
polynomials using this proof system but
if I can find such a proof then this
proof can be made algorithmic and sort
of so Boas brock's we've done a lot of
work on this and he has this thing which
he calls
marlis theorem
and quotes which more or less says that
if your proof only uses simple facts
about tea very polynomial of n very
polynomials of degree T then the sum of
squares algorithm can also prove the
same fact in time and to the oft ok and
simple facts include stuff like holders
inequality some more or less everything
that I showed you before is in the SS
proof system and that's why was
important that these troops are simple
because what it's going to imply is that
the SOS algorithm can solve it in into
the oft time and as Boas says the reason
why he calls it Marley's theorem is
because you just prove your inequality
don't worry about it but if you've done
everything right then everything is
going to be all right okay so we want to
view the problem of finding subjects and
subsets as some optimization problems
and polynomial optimization problem such
that we can frame it kind of in the
framework of SOS ok so here was the
problem just to recall this is the
problem this is like what it means to
find a sub y I should subset we want to
find a sub guess a subset s of size
alpha n where alpha some parameter now
and the point is that you need to have
this sort of bounded moment condition
when you project your data in all
directions you simultaneously okay so
how we're gonna do this well okay so the
first part is maybe not too hard we have
some sub selection problem this uh you
need a sub select some set of our data
so what we do is for each J in one
through n we choose a W J so that W J is
in zero one so this this is posting code
whether or not it's in my subset or not
it's going to have some size constraint
you know some of the WJ is supposed to
be alpha N and we're just gonna encode
the empirical mean as this linear
constraint on the w i's okay so we the x
i's are fixed them are polynomials our
programs gonna be over the WS okay and
then finally we're going to have this
condition
and once done I wanted to mention was
that in some sense what's going on with
Ephron's well we showed in 2016 is that
this Twitter program there's some
caveats here is not quite right but this
program has more or less a simple very
simple like degree to wish relaxation
and so you don't have to deal with any
of this nonsense
but in this more complicated setting we
have to take a much more sophisticated
relaxation they're the same problem to
get the guarantees that we want and I
guess we should mention that in an
equivalent way of writing the constraint
that WJ is in 0 1 is to say this WJ
squared is equal to W J so this is
really polynomial constraint on W J's
right now so everything is OK
except for their turns out this to be an
important caveat which is this all this
for all constraint that we need that
this polynomial equation so if you fixed
a single vector U and just had this this
would be a nice polynomial inequality
and everything would be nice but we have
this for all u in Rd and sort of SOS at
least in this most basic form doesn't
deal well with these for all constraints
so how do we do it so we need to somehow
enforce this condition this for all
condition in some nice SOS table way one
naive way to do it would be to just
replace it with some stronger constraint
and it turns out the following spectral
constraint on the teeth tensor suffice
is is not important to really parse this
but this just says that there's some
control over kind of a flattening of the
tensor and this is a bit weird right
because now this not quite a polynomial
WJ again because this is a saying this
is a matrix polynomial double J and
saying that it's BST bounded by
something but it turns out that this
constraint can also be enforced using an
extension of SOS called matrix SOS
that'd be good except that
tip that there's an issue with
feasibility so if the sub joshan points
really true truly come from a Gaussian
it turns out that you can show that you
know the true set of points will satisfy
this inequality so this would work for
instance already for learning a kg mm
but it's not clear if this works for
general subjection distributions and
indeed it doesn't seem to be true so we
need to do something more sophisticated
and this is yeah I'm having issues with
this so we need to impose some kind of
more stringent conditions on our
distribution so what we're going to say
is that we're gonna have the following
definition which is that if a
distribution you're gonna say at this
region D has T explicitly bounded moment
if this inequality as a polynomial in U
so this is sort of you know this defined
some polynomial in U and this is some
polynomial view if this inequality has a
degree T SOS proof okay so there's a
weird-looking statement
oh sorry this should be sifted shifted
by than me yeah yeah wrong you know so
but so this is like a polynomial in U
and this is also polynomial you when I
fixed the so I just need this to be true
and also provable in SOS sort of as a
polynomial inequality yeah no I mean you
need it to be like not too much bigger
like it's gonna come into the final
runtime of your algorithm but yeah this
could be like poly T or whatever so this
is a weird-looking constraint it's not
we don't really fully understand it to
be honest but it still encompasses a
very large class of distributions so not
quite also not all subtraction
distributions will have this property
but it turns out that it includes a lot
of things like actions products
rotations and also Kothari and
steinhardt shows that it includes all
distributions satisfying a certain
isoparametric inequality which is like
these punk grade distributions which
encompass a very large class of
distributions more or less I would like
to say like everything that we care
about but I guess I shouldn't go that
far but it's a large class of nice
distributions still have this property
and then in this setting in terms that
you can't you still can't quite do
matrix SOS or anything like this but you
can do something else and the idea is
that now what we know is that if our
distribution or if our subset of points
has its subduction then not only is it
like subduction it has a simple
certificate that its sub Gaussian
because this is a simple certificate
because it's an SOS proof is a simple
certificate that something happens and
so what our program can actually do in
the end is look for a set of points and
this simple certificate simultaneously
and it turns out everything is convex
because the set of SOS proofs is convex
and what we're doing is also convex and
the rest of our variables so I don't
really want to get into it but the idea
is that because we have a nice simple
characterization of what's supposed to
be looking for we can look for a very
simple way of finding
okay so in the end more or less what
we're going to do is we design an SCP
from the fos hierarchy to find a sub -
in subset of points because our simple
identifiability proofs that I showed you
these holder style arguments are simple
they're going to lift to SOS and that
means that whatever the solution in SOS
finds must also respect these
constraints that I showed you and
because they are going to satisfy these
very nice properties they're kind of
trivially round able because he has to
be solution is integral so you can just
design some simple rounding algorithm to
recover the means that's more or less it
and that's also the case for robust mean
estimation okay so I think I'm pretty
much out of time so let me wrap up yeah
so we leverage the power of SOS to
design these new algorithms for learning
while separate mixture models and robust
mean estimation and sort of the
principle of it is to find a subset of
points that SOS can verify some nice
property of and they're also inspired by
techniques from bus estimation and the
kind of key point is that all these
proofs lift - SOS because they only ever
use very simple identities about the
data okay
all right so here's some open problems
that I'm still thinking about so one
interesting question in general is it
kind of not well form problem but in
general you know this is somehow saying
that SOS can certify some properties of
subsets of data this this the sub joshan
subsets in general you know what other
properties of subsets of data can SOS to
verify so there's actually very Incheon
question I think like Sam has some
recent work that you can present
sometime about like using this to verify
some order statistics and high
dimensions and this makes some like
median style estimators very efficient
in high dimensions which is not known
before some more concrete questions are
like can we you know improve robots Co
variance estimation not just mean
estimation can we improve the sample
complexity in run time it's not clear
how much you can do this because there
are these tumor vascular bounds and
finally can you apply our framework to
other sorts of clustering crumbs
[Applause]
questions
hello question yeah so why doesn't this
result immediately work for make sure so
I mean we're all we're still using this
like geometric separation oh sorry so
the question was like why do why do we
need why doesn't this work for like
mixtures of like arbitrary Gaussian and
the answer it at least the short answer
is we're still heavily leveraging the
fact that we have l2 separation between
the gaussians between the means of the
Gaussian this is the thing that we're
using when you have like arbitrary
mixtures of gaussians even if they're
separated in some reasonable sense you
need to like figure out what the sort of
the metric is between distributions or
some scaling that you need to also
implicitly learn and we don't know how
to do that right now and of at the same
time as doing everything else
very popular point of view polynomial on
time but this is what they kind of like
well so alright so what I stated was
like these I had these like a hundreds
and stuff you can we can make that
tighter but this on says these problems
are they have these SQ lower bounds as
Ilyas is going to present pretty soon
and the says says somehow the sort of
like the source of like K to the one
over epsilon sorts of runtimes are
unavoidable at least even the sample
complexity so these you can match the
sample if I see one time like and you
can probably get you know pretty
efficient in whatever the awful sample
complexity is but somehow you can't hope
to really improve that with efficient
algorithms unless you can be this cute
okay but for like robust mean estimation
and like listen learning this is no so I
guess I'd be somewhat skeptical if you
could so you know strongly improve our
own times but
all right looks like jig again have a
break